one of my favorite tweets in early in
the trump history i think it was 2018.
it was from this actress i forgot who
who it was but it was it was from in los
angeles and she she tweeted out that
oh there's immigration checkpoints and
so she's speaking to her fellows
tell your gardeners to tell your
housemates tell them to avoid this area
and ever just like wait why are you just
why are you why are you automatically
assuming that to tell there but but it's
true because that
is that is a majority of their set and
so when they think about immigrants
it's oh it's my it's the help yeah
exactly
and it's just it's just it's just so
patronizing and it's just so fake and
i'm tired of it yeah yeah so so i i just
i just pulled up the article because i
had to make sure i had it right
kelly kelly osborne she said if you kick
out latinos who's gonna be cleaning your
toilet uh
what these people again they just see us
as a political tool to hit republicans
with and to clean their toilets and
cause their fears
i'm going to read this quote and i'm
going to be very precise
and annoying how i read this for
political purposes because they're going
to call us out of context
kelly osborne said if you kick every
latino out of this country
then who is and this is this is what uh
kelly osborne said
going to be cleaning your toilet donald
trump you know what i mean
osborne said in an attempt to call out
the republican presidential candidate
who faced massive backlash no that's not
no interrupted co-host rosie perez
continuing there's more jobs than that
in the country for latinos and latinos
are not the only people who clean
toilets
and she immediately backtracked i i
didn't mean it like that come on i would
never mean it like that
dude you totally meant it like that and
it was only when she got
snapback she was like oh oh is that
wrong am i not allowed to say that
i thought we're on the same page here
yeah this is it think about it's not
even about latinos or or mexicans or
people from honduras it is about cheap
immigrant labor
and it used to be who was it bernie
sanders bernie sanders warned about how
the koch brothers
brothers supported open immigration
because it would work work
great for their big corporations yeah
you get some dude who comes in working
below minimum wage no benefits because
they're under they're off the books
under the table
and then you basically have an
underclass
then vox.com the progressive website
wrote in 2016
the democratic party has become is
becoming the party of the wealthy elites
so it's no surprise then the democrats
are the ones who are now saying oh we
got to have
more immigration and open borders it's
remarkable trump ran on the republican
ticket
saying border security no free trade and
it worked because regular americans were
like yeah
i like this idea of you know america
first the big business
special interest corporations and the
ultra wealthy were like
how am i going to hire ultra cheap
labor with no rights if the republican
is doing this all of a sudden the
democrats were now like yeah open
borders
even though what in 2008 2010 you had
democrats who were like we have to build
a border security barrier
that was due the 2006 the secure fence
yeah joe
joe biden voted for uh voted for that
offense so you're calling joe biden a
racist
oh snap i think he called himself that
but and so even even with all that and
that's why
when they're saying oh you know
president trump's not building any new
fence just replacing the old one well
the 2000 the one that was built in 2006
was basically just glorified chicken
wire
and you can be easily cut into within
minutes right and so this new one that
that that they're replacing along with
areas where there was no barrier it
takes hours and
the whole point is to slow them down and
to actually get border patrol agents to
that
area so that they can either stop them
or arrest them and so it's just
a lot of misinformation a lot of you
know yeah rhetoric as
it typically does but because i've been
there i've been all over el paso laredo
san diego and it's just it's just
amazing when you
like when you're actually there and you
see it and you see the difference it's
just
it's just amazing it's remarkable how
the democrats really rely on you not
knowing anything
and so they'll be like donald trump
didn't build new border wall he only
replaced existing wall
if you've never seen it you're imagining
this giant wall and trump comes in and
just
takes out a wall and puts in a wall and
nothing changed and then when you
actually look at it
the original wall was like some fence
posts with a single like log across it
that you could just like walk and limbo
under yeah and then trump put triple
reinforced you know barricades with b
with cbp in between
and it's like yeah those are very
different things
and then when they're like yeah but
trump should be building new wallets
like but those are the hot spots that
the trump supporters
wanted secured right so like trump
wasn't giving his supporters a 30-foot
big beautiful concrete wall from sea to
shining sea paid for by mexico
but he was reinforcing areas with you
know strong security in a border wall
where it was
most effective also the conversation
changed because previously before we had
individuals like bernie sanders
that were talking about how if we have a
lot
of people entering the labor force wages
are going to go down
on the basic understanding of supply and
demand economics
that conversation is not happening
anymore that conversation
about the average worker the average
person trying to make a living wage
that's not factored in anymore and it
should be and that should be a big part
of the conversation
i think it's just special interests they
they want to make a quick buck
they've hijacked it's really clever i'll
put it this way
you know it's a lot easier to
to be on the side of social justice and
have all these institutions supporting
you
but i got to say these people who think
they're fighting for you know social
justice and things like that
you you really think these billion
dollar corporations and these meat
packing plants
care about their workers look when they
slap a rainbow sticker over their logo
they're doing it so that you stop
fighting against them
and it works it does not completely well
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna be naive
enough or or you know stupid enough
to try and argue that legitimate
principled left-wing activists are gonna
stop arguing against corporations
because they put a rainbow up
but a lot of the establishment democrat
voters the people who don't
investigate news who are not
particularly active stop being active
when they're like yeah we did it
coca-cola agrees with us
they tell they told everyone to be less
white the fight's over oh there you go
by the way do you guys have any coke no
no we probably do have coke products
somewhere why do you want something to
drink oh no i just want to be lost
oh yeah me too did you guys see the the
g prime 85 comic
oh the rcs the art we have on the walls
is from george alex opolis and he made
one where it's a white woman being
baptized
in coca-cola that's messed up
what was the tagline with that uh i
forgot the title
diabetes yeah yeah but the power of
diabetes
i grant you away from your whiteness or
something like that
i'm thinking about my time in la i
worked at a restaurant for a long time
and had a lot of friends there that were
from
the central america that came over
illegally and were basically
extracting wealth from the country
because they would get paid in cash
and then they would send the money to
mexico to their families
and then they would work in the u.s for
a couple years and then leave and go be
super rich in mexico
relatively rich yeah and they were super
cool great friends
um and it was a small business so
they're basically it's not just the big
corporations but if the small business
can't survive
if they have to pay full wages it's hard
to pay taxes and rent and everything
there was a big movement for a while
about local currencies do you guys know
about this like
ithaca hours was a big thing where
basically there was money that was only
good in the town of ithaca new york
so if you worked they could be like we
could pay you in u.s dollars or ithaca
hours
and this this it was like one hour of
labor equaled a one
hour note and you could trade it for
food and goods
in this place so it had real value among
the community
what th what this did was it ensured
that the trade medium could not leave
the city
right so if you got a city like detroit
and then the auto plants close down and
leave
now there's no more dollars coming in
people don't have anything to trade with
so with local currencies that currency
is always there
that's why i think it's relevant to
bring up with what you're saying ian
when people come to the us work under
the table
and don't pay taxes i'm not saying none
of them pay taxes i'm saying but when
the specific
when they specifically don't they're not
giving back to the system they're
getting from
they're using our infrastructure then
that money is extracted from the system
and sent
overseas to whatever country their
family is in their families then can
then use that
because the standard standard of living
will be lower so it goes a lot further
in those places
but that means there is less currency in
that town to circulate among the people
who live there
ultimately an extraction of the labor
value of that area the
the re so it's basically like the labor
being brought in
is being traded away to other countries
and other places
over time it's an extraction from the us
you combine that with outsourcing
factoring factories being sent overseas
and open borders and
yeah you're going to see seriously
detrimental economic effects in this
country
and that's why you get a donald trump
because regular americans look at this
when you look at the original thing we
were talking about the democrats saying
trump support are bad
and trump's reporters saying illegal
immigration bad it sounds like the trump
supporters the conservatives or
republicans
are looking at the data and thinking
what will make things better in this
country well we got a problem with
illegal immigration for a variety of
reasons
the democrats are like republicans are
bad it's like that's not a policy
problem that doesn't mean anything
republicans are actually saying this is
an issue
what do the democrats do to combat the
fact that republicans are talking about
a legitimate policy debate
they say they're racist they just hate
brown people that's the only explanation
they hate brown people they're
xenophobic i hate myself
yeah how dare you be yeah you be
conservative and and not white that's
not allowed oh i've been called a race
trainer multiple times
i love how they tell they tell my people
to be race traders
uh i'm sorry not to not to be race
traders but then they call they tell
white people to be race traders
you know what i mean yeah so like they
have that whiteness chart that was like
went out at that school and it said like
be a race trader and it's like okay go
tell it to anybody who's not white no
and they say but it's not about race
yeah that was a principal in new york
city who sent a pamphlet
to all the parents in that high school
that by the way
you know there was i think i think 70
percent 17
of the kids were white that that it's
good to be a white
trader like what yes we could probably
pull up the article new york city
principal hands out
woke pamphlet and then you could see the
pamphlet in itself it was based off of
some
university professor that created a
scale of whiteness asking white people
to rate themselves
and one of the better scales to be at is
to be a a white
uh race traitor um oh that's right
because you're like either complicit in
white supremacy or exactly here we go
yeah i found it yeah okay so this is
from we got this one from syracuse.com
new york principal asks students parents
to reflect on their
whiteness and he has there's this tweet
christopher ruffa who we've had he's
great
is the one who i think he broke the
story and it's the eight white
identities
i think we talked about this on the show
like the other day or whatever but it's
it's
it's definitely worth bringing up
because it literally says to be a white
trader
it's like it's green you know it's like
white supremacist is red bad bad red
and then white privilege is like orange
it's like there's like a wheel where
it's like
red to yellow to green what is that
white voyeurism
i don't know what that means like you
you like people
watching you like watching white people
right right no yeah
that's a boy yeah yeah exhibitionism is
when you like people watching you right
right right right yeah
and voyeurism is when you like watching
others yep really weird like you like
watching white people
and then there's white benefit white
confessional white critical
white traitor and white abolitionist
white confessional
yeah this is a cult man it's it's it's a
weird race cult
yeah yuck i just want them to stop
putting making latinx a thing oh my gosh
yeah well i just well well and then um i
forgot i forgot who tweeted it but they
they show
they tweeted a picture of an article i
think it's like a food magazine but
there's a philippine ex
where it's just like i mean it's just
it's just completely insulting
i mean well one it's like they're
starting to realize that how machismo
and how actually gendered
the spanish language is and i mean well
there you go
at the end of every spanish word it's
either a male or
female romantic yeah yeah and it go and
so it goes against that orthodoxy of
gender fluid
fluidity and all and all this stuff and
so it's just
they're trying to act like well we're
saving you from yourselves of being
sexist and
oppressive towards people who don't
identify as that it's just like well or
maybe you're being raised you're the
ones being racist because you're
literally destroying the foundation of
the language of
use you speak spanish yeah a little bit
i only speak a little bit
i just love the idea of them saying
latinx but
they don't actually know how to speak
the language could you imagine trying to
speak spanish where you replaced the
ozines with exes
oh oh they're headaches they well one
they they look at you weirdos
comedics comedics there was like pig
latin
it was it was like uh there was a gallup
poll i believe it was gallup that that
showed
it was like 90 percent of hispanics had
never even heard
of that and how do you even describe
latinx like what does it mean where did
it come from
because i don't even like it's just it's
just to denote that
you're just trying to make a gender
neutral to be sensitive to to others but
but
like the overall latino community just
rejects it and so yeah i got it pulled
up about one in four u.s hispanics have
heard of latinx
but just three percent use it read the
next line young hispanic women among
those most likely to use the terms
college yep how do you how do you how do
you so it's it's not just spanish though
it's like romance languages have
gendered words
so like bon journix what is
what mussolini changed the uh was the
linux
the gender of the sex you guys
everything muslims yeah yeah it was good
the river the the great italian river uh
was a
had the female gender and he made it
male and was like we are a
masculine country so there is something
dangerous about
you know take making something male or
female dominating i think
against could you could oppress a gender
that way but i don't know if it
necessarily does
the argument i made was so uh you do
speak a little bit you guys speak a
little bit of spanish
what is uh what does nino mean little
guy little boy
what does ninos mean little boys what
does nina mean
little girl what does ninjas mean little
girls but what if i said
los ninos and pointed to a group of
school children what does that mean yeah
boys and girls well it can be okay yeah
right because so yeah so the point i
would always bring up is
the word that's supposed to be for boy
could actually reference girls as well
but women get an exclusive word just for
themselves that's privilege
so if you see a group of children boys
and girls you would say los ninos
but nino is masculine yet women get
included in the masculine as well
but men don't get included in the
feminine so i'm not seriously
complaining with the language but i was
actually talking it's like
15 years ago sometimes a feminist who
was complaining to this about me when i
was like teenager in chicago
and i was like how is it how is it fair
that you know women get exclusive words
to describe themselves
but the masculine words are used to
describe both so women get both words
i was being somewhat facetious to point
out the language itself is not sexist
it's just true it's just a way to
describe things
but give look man you could make
something up and and
someone probably could do this find
something that could be presumably
perceived as sexist
and then they'll latch on to it i don't
know start arguing that we should
we did you know that the modern banana
was
artificially selected so it did not
evolve naturally
humans were picking the bananas that
they liked
and then only replanting the ones that
were better and better
eventually we end up with this big
sugary wad that's not even got seeds in
it you know what i mean
like original bananas used to have all
these different all these different
seeds it's very starchy and not sweet
so what you got to do now is you gotta
tell them it's sexist it was the men
choosing the dick shaped fruit what yeah
because of patriarchy
it's about time we start artificially
selecting bananas to not be shaped like
weiners wieners no but it's the
stupidest idea ever
but you could make something like that
up oh spanish is sexist because there's
gendered language okay well then like
basically every romance language is is
sexist they're they're going to get
there they just want to focus on the
brown people first
yeah yeah yeah because it's the it's the
white progressives who who know better
for you
you know i mean it's very condescending
i mean like like honestly like i don't
get like to actually like quote unquote
like triggered about stuff but that that
actually upsets me just because it's
just
they i understand what they're trying to
do but it just it just it's just done in
such a
completely um inconsiderate and not in
in a serious way and it's self-defeating
taking the gender out of the language
well right yeah well because they're
they're they're they're signaling that
we don't know that we're being sexist
and so they're coming to the rest
why is why is comida food is feminine
is that is that fair it's sexist that
food is for women like
who cares about it it's just it's just
yeah it's just it's just whatever i mean
that's why they don't give it a second
thought
the arabic's interesting i don't wanna i
don't wanna mis-exemplify it but i'm
pretty sure
in arabic it's if a woman is saying
something or if a man is saying
something they use
different language or is it if you're
talking to a woman you use a different
way of you use a different phrase than
if you're talking to a man that might
yeah sounds
it's very impossible i would say very
strange because i'm not used to it
i grew up uh in a polish area chicago's
got a very very large polish community
shout out to kashmir pulaski saw a great
tweet from uh jack pasok about that
but uh i didn't learn this until
recently and luke confirmed
that they actually give women different
last names
yeah so how does that work what is that
what is that what's that all about well
it's
it's
feminine and male so usually usually a
polish name is about a ski
for for when it's for a man and ska when
it's for a woman
so the patriarchy of poland they don't
even give women the name of the men
they say no no you get a different one
you're a scar not a ski skis are only
for men
see that's the patriarchy my dad likes
god music there you go
the funny thing about it though is like
i don't know if that's sexist or not but
you could argue it
is you can say it's not fair the men
refused to give
the women their full name and give them
the derivative
ska instead of the true ski but then you
could also argue like modern feminism in
america
where it's like i shouldn't have to take
the last name of the man anyway
there's always a way to frame the
argument to make it seem like someone's
being bigger when it literally doesn't
right
it's just so tiring the word men is in
the word women
so that's sexist the word he is in the
word she
so that's sexist they've tried doing it
with
his
her story it's it's you know it's uh
there's a really funny meme where
someone said like for a while feminists
were claiming that woe
wo means belong to so woe men means
property of men but that's actually not
true the original uh um etymology i
believe of the word is
where men and whitman and so that's
where a werewolf comes from
so a werman was a male man was a male
human and a whiffman was a male a female
human and then over time probably
because men were the ones engaging in
political affairs
the patriarchy the the wear dropped off
and just became
men and then women retained the the
whiffman
you know suffix or prefix or whatever so
long story short
there's there's like evolution of
language happens and it's really easy to
make anything seem like a conspiracy
or or or you know bigoted or racist and
they exploit that
they exploit sophistry to convince
unsuspecting people who have who are of
good faith and goodwill
into doing for them and for for those
that think critically
you know to the to the chagrin of the
new york times they don't fall for this
stuff
they end up watching shows like this you
guys are great but a lot of people just
fall for cnn they'll turn it on and
they'll be like you know latinx and
they'll go yes
i saw disney also they had when they
were celebrating hispanic heritage month
they
and that's the other thing too you can
just say hispanic like like that's
like that's generator too yeah it's like
there's latin america i mean there's
just there's other options
like why why do you have to go after
that and again i don't want to like
seem like i'm just triggered over words
but it's just it's just it's it's the
deeper
uh mindset that they have of like we
know better than you do
and you're it's and if you go against us
you're i love it
it's a most it's an ideology derived
mostly from white leftists
to tell minorities how to speak and i'm
like how do you define white supremacy
a bunch of white academics of privilege
telling minorities what to say and think
and do
i mean that sounds like you know better
it sounds a bit like white supremacy to
me
you know i'm not going to tell you you
can say whatever you want i don't know i
don't think it's about
gender i don't think it's about sex or
anything like that i don't think it's
about gender roles i think it's about
controlling the narrative and this is
something we've talked about in the past
we've talked about changing the language
so you can change stuff like the laws
i think it's a matter of sneaky trying
to force the evolution of a language to
suit your own
power goals i i honestly think it's
that's true like we talked about how if
you can change the definition of the
word gender
then every law on the books becomes a
different law
so when the law was written right like
the 1960 1964 civil rights act and they
say
you know or or derivative policies in
various jurisdictions when they say
you may not discriminate on the basis of
gender well back then they specifically
meant
male or female today the activists left
at all in all these institutions has
changed the definition of gender
once people accept it they say look the
law says you can't discriminate the
basis of gender
well i'm you know hydro-gender so you
can't discriminate
and then they show up dressed up in a
full body you know jacuzzi suit
or something you know more actually
they'd be pretty sweet have you seen
those jacuzzi suits oh wait is it real
i'm pretty i think they might be real i
mean maybe maybe it's something i saw
maybe i dreamed it
yeah that's like a fever dream right
there if you don't have a copy no i
think i saw it on tv once
i don't know but you know what i mean
i'm just trying to be absurd like
if if if the law was originally intended
to address
males and females and now that we've
changed language you're going to argue
the law is different that's a way to
exploit the system
to change laws without actually having
the votes to change the laws
it seems to be a lot of what they're
doing i don't think of it that way but
yeah
i do think a lot of it is just random
though like when they say wymixon do you
guys know what wimmickson is
no wow
that pop up like a month ago i was like
how did where did that come from because
they like putting exes on things
it's it's like a little kid being like
i'm gonna call myself
the the thunder smasher that's my new
name and the mom is like
billy that's not your name your name is
william stop calling yourself
thundersmasher
and you can't write on your exam at
school thundersmasher anymore because
your name is william it's like no i'm a
i'm
thundersmasher it's like a little kid
just trying to be cool no i'm going to
put an x at the end of my award because
x's are cool you wanna know what's
really funny about the letter x x means
christ
in christianity so i want everybody to
think about that every time they see the
word woman center folks think about it
oh
no there you go about them thinking
about religion because
the people that want to crush the
patriarchy or undo this this there's
something to it because like if you look
at the way the bible is written
eve came from adam's rib in the story
like the man
everyone knows that humans are born from
women that's just the way things are
wasn't lilith
wasn't there a woman before eve no
really you're sure yeah
100 yeah they wrote the book for this
like mystical
woman was created from a dude's rib like
look the man came
first the man is the center in the
beginning but like
no he was born from a woman they just
write her into the story
and so these people want to kind of
trash that i mean this really a bunch of
old white dudes
wrote the bible and like had the council
of nicaea and rewrote took out what they
wanted to make it tell a story to
give men power but the women are the
most power like the women are the center
of the family they are the creator of
the human
and so i see these people wanting to
kind of
bend or or break things back to the way
i just a different way i don't know
i just have to you know interject though
right go ahead interject
lilith appears as adam's first wife who
was created at the same time and from
the same clay as adam
this contrasts with eve who was created
from one of adam's ribs
lilith is the legend of the first woman
is a 19th century rendition of the old
rabbinical legend of lilith the first
woman
whose life story was dropped unrecorded
from the early world
and whose home hope and eden were passed
to another woman
so not in the bible right okay yeah well
it does about it
are they yeah yeah right right right
right so maybe it's it's an old
rabbinical legend
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you